au pays la nouvelle écosse était la
première à écoper avec des rafales de
150 kilomètres à l'heure et des
accumulations de près de 150 millimètres
depuis par endroits des toitures ont été
arrachés des arbres déracinés des lignes
électriques sectionnés
au plus fort de la tempête vous près de
quatre cent mille foyers étaient privés
de courant
halifax une grue s'est effondrée contre
un bâtiment ne faisant heureusement
aucun blessé
les autorités ont demandé à la
population habitant le littoral de la
ville d'évacuer volontairement en raison
de la menace que représentaient des
vagues d'une quinzaine de mètres
le sud-est du nouveau-brunswick et
l'île-du-prince-édouard n'était pas en
reste des dizaines de milliers de foyers
étaient sans électricité
des vents violents ont soufflé des
débris sur des kilomètres à la ronde des
résidences et des véhicules ont subi
d'importants dommages
les liaisons par traversée ont aussi été
perturbés tempête a fait des siennes
jusqu en acadie plus au nord où des
chalets ont été inondées la tempête post
tropicale se trouvait ce matin au
nord-est des îles de la madeleine ou
environnement canada signalé des rafales
de 120 kilomètres à l'heure des portions
de la route 199 ont été submergés et
encombrées de débris entraînant sa
fermeture temporaire les berges
assailli par les vagues ont beaucoup
souffert des bateaux et des embarcations
de toutes sortes ont été renversées des
quais ont été démolies à la marina de
l'île du havre aubert les nombreux
voiliers qui était stationnée s'empilent
maintenant ici louis de belleval radio
canada montréal